my show
so
this
yeah
so
you know
five
yes
okay
now
wow
thank you
so
so
hey
foreign
good afternoon everybody thank you very
much for
for coming for joining us
it's all too easy to come to a summit
like this and get caught up in a mood of
exaggerated enthusiasm
uh simply because of the very nature of
of diplomacy and the instinct to
be polite
so as this first stage of the cop 26
draws to a close and don't forget there
are still two weeks of detailed
negotiation to come we must take care to
guard against false hope and not to
think uh in any way that the job is done
because it is not there is still a very
long way to go
but all that
being said
i am cautiously optimistic
in the sense that
on the way to
the g20 in rome i said to some of you on
the plane that if this was a football
match then the current score would be
5-1 down
in the in the match between humanity and
climate change
and
i think what you could say today after
two days of
talks with around 120 world leaders
is that we've pulled back
a goal or perhaps even two
and i think we're going to be able
to take this thing to extra time because
there's no doubt that
some progress has been made
we're ending the great chainsaw massacre
with more than 85 of the world's forests
to be protected by the end of this
decade an unprecedented agreement by
122 countries now backed by the biggest
ever commitment of public funds for
forest conservation with much more still
to come from the private sector
we've got 90 percent of the world's
economy working towards net zero up from
less than a third when the uk took up
the cop reigns including india keeping a
billion tons of carbon out of the
atmosphere by switching half its power
grid to renewable sources
more than 100 countries have just signed
up to cut their methane emissions by
2030
when we were selected as
hosts of cop26
just one percent of the world's economy
had met
the post-paris obligation to improve on
their 2030 emission targets today
that figure stands at 80 percent
and it's not just that we're putting
forward better targets or bigger targets
the world has been actually putting
forward the plans to reach those targets
billions of dollars have been committed
to supporting developing and vulnerable
countries
big business has stepped up with the
launch of the the glasgow breakthroughs
this afternoon and our clean green
initiative uh idea the build-back better
world idea that joe biden talks about is
is catching on and it's taking the green
industrial revolution worldwide for
example
we're working with south africa's
president ramaposa to deliver his
ambitious vision for faster greener
growth
and
what i would say is
we've been asking for action
as you know on coal cars cash and trees
and after just a couple of days we can
certainly
begin
to tick three of those boxes you can
begin we're beginning to write the tick
and
that's all happened because we were able
to come together in person in glasgow
and and do this make it happen at cop26
and of course it's only part of the
story
although the uk has this week committed
a further billion dollars of
international climate finance taking uh
our total to twelve point six billion
pounds by twenty twenty five twelve
point six billion pounds that we're
committing to climate change actually
just a few hours ago japan announced
another 10 billion dollars over the next
five years a big commitment from japan
the reality is
that the developed world will still be
late
in hitting
the 100 billion target and it's
brilliant that so many countries have
embraced net zero uh this week
but we're going to keep working with all
the leaders around the world to get them
there sooner to accelerate their
timetable
we've now predicted uh 85 we've got
measures to protect 85 percent of the
world's forests and 90 percent of the
world's economy working to net zero
those commitments will be 100
useless
if the promises made here are not
followed up with real action
as prime minister mia motley of barbados
so passionately warned us yesterday
climate change
is not some parochial political issue
for tens of millions of people around
the world it is literally a matter of
life or death they need
those economies need 1.5 to survive
so
i'll be watching proceedings we'll be
watching proceedings very closely to
make sure we keep moving forward and
there are no u-turns no sliding back
from where we've got to
but i think we can be confident about
one thing in the days ahead the couple
of weeks we've got
the clock on the doomsday device that i
talked about is is still ticking
but we've got a bomb disposal team on
site and they're starting to snip
the wires i have some of the right wires
and
my message to them
to the negotiators is is very simple the
leaders of the world may have left or
are leaving cop now but i can tell you
that the eyes of the world the eyes of
the populations of the world are on you
in the eyes of the british government
and all the other governments that care
about this are on our negotiators and we
have your numbers thank you all very
much i'm going to go to
the uh to the media now and we'll begin
with laura koonsberg of the bbc
thank you very much prime minister um
the chinese have said today that there
are still significant gaps we know also
that the leader of the un has said he's
worried there isn't enough trust between
developing countries and developed
countries to be able to get a deal over
the line
you've said that
the leaders of the world have scored a
couple of goals improved things from 5-1
but what or who is going to score the
extra two or three goals you still need
thank you laura i think that's
that's entirely right in the sense that
the issues remain
very difficult
we've seen some big moves on on on
tackling deforestation uh that you you
that i've talked about i think the
indian uh move on decarbonizing their uh
their power system of getting towards
renewables uh in the way that they're uh
they're pledging to do is is is
huge and terrific uh i think that the
uh
the commitment that japan made on on
cash for 10 billion over five years
that's that's that's big money and that
will make a a big difference in in in
you know engendering that that
confidence
laura but i think the crucial thing that
is is really happening if there's one
thing that starts to give me uh
confidence or optimism anyway it's that
uh we are starting to create for the
countries that find it most difficult to
transition away from fossil fuels we're
starting to create those those
coalitions of of support uh to help them
to move on and so to help cyril
ramaphosa of of south africa in his in
his vision uh several countries
including the uk
are now working to supply uh eight and a
half billion dollars uh to to help
accelerate that transition away from
cold help decarbonize uh the uh the
south african economy in a in a major
way and you're starting to see that kind
of approach taken
around the world with some of the
countries that find it most difficult
and if i had to i i told you i was i was
at paris and i remember what it was like
and we had this great sense that we'd
agreed this thing that we were gonna we
were gonna uh try and cut co2 together
but it was also a slightly floaty
feeling because we didn't know how on
earth we were going to do it and there
was no road map there was no very clear
sense of how you could do it i think
what you're starting to see
uh here at cop 26 in glasgow is a sense
of how actually you can deliver those
cuts in in co2 but you know i'm not
going to disagree with you laura there
is a long way
to go anushka starter of itv
thank you um prime minister i'm not sure
if the prime minister of belize would
share your cautious optimism i spoke to
him today and he said developed
countries are not doing enough he said
that the west got rich on lavish
lifestyles and that now it was telling
developing countries they couldn't do
that he says if that is your message
then they need much more money and much
more action so let me ask
do you understand the anger of the prime
minister of belize and also you're not
going to get a deal that's good enough
on coal are you
i think you're absolutely right anushka
to
to highlight the feelings of uh people
in uh in belize uh but in vulnerable
states around the world that that are in
the front line in the fight against
against climate change and it's been
very humbling to to sit here uh
and to listen over the last weeks months
to colleagues from mia motley and bobby
you heard her at the un general assembly
say the same thing
uh why should they suffer this immediate
impact this is this and damage because
of
of emissions that we in our country
began to produce 250 years ago now we
can say well for for the vast majority
of that period we had no idea that the
co2 emissions we were producing were
doing that damage it's only really been
in the last few decades that we started
to understand
the whole greenhouse uh effect
but we have we owe a special duty to
those countries and that's why uh the
the prime minister of belize is right to
point to the need for cash uh that's why
the hundred billion
is so important
and it's good that japan has has stepped
up but other countries are going to have
to to do more you know you're absolutely
right
uh
what we need
is to see more cash we need to see more
movement on
our cars we haven't even discussed cars
yet
you know that's that's for that's for
later on that's for the next few few
days there are we we must see progress
on on that too uh i think we've made
some good progress on on trees but when
it comes to helping countries to
transition then a huge effort is is
needed what i think we have is this is
the is the tools to do it and we
certainly have in theory we have the
finance to do it
you know the uh mark carney who's
running the global finance initiative
here would say that there are hundreds
of trillions of dollars that's how other
people would say it was tens of
trillions you know it's still a huge
amount of money and that money can be
leveraged in by the public sector and by
our our investments so
i'm not going to disagree
with what uh the prime minister of
belize has said uh
or indeed with anybody who says that the
world
in the in the remaining days that we
have in this comp the world has a lot
lot more to do uh mesa hall of the
express and beth i'm your next
mesa
thank you thank you very much prime
minister um a couple of days ago you put
the chances of success here at about six
to ten uh six in ten i just wondered if
you had a new figure for that after the
talks today
and um outside of the enthusiasm that
you've talked about in this summit uh in
the country a lot of people are
concerned about the cost implications of
the the dash the net zero what it might
mean for them and their families some of
your mps are concerned about it um about
a week ago a poll suggested that a
majority of people would like to see a
referendum on the idea of net zero would
you
as a seasoned referendum campaigner
would you think about that
uh thanks mason look i just want to say
uh one thing about the overall uh
economics of the first of all uh if we
don't do this
if we don't fix our climate it will be
an economic catastrophe
as well as a as an environmental
catastrophe right
i think people need to understand that
as point number one th this is the only
way to to fix this is to is to reduce uh
co2 and and tackle climate change i also
happen to think that there's a great
wisdom in uh in the british people and i
think that they can see that this is
that is is an issue that needs to be
fixed and they may not listen to to me
but they certainly listen to
sir david attenborough and they look at
what's actually happening around the
world they look at the fires they look
at the floods and they look at the
hurricanes and the the increased
incidence of all three
much increased incidents and they think
something's happening here
and they look at that graph you see that
that graph on the yesterday morning
incredibly powerful graph that sir david
attenborough produced of the increase in
uh in co2 emissions over the last few
thousand years uh the the the
the co the graph of co2 emissions and
then the temperatures and how
temperatures track co2 emissions and
then that spike
in co2 emissions that anthropogenic
spike vertical movement upwards and
accompanied now we're seeing by
increases in temperature and they can
see that and they're not they're not
done and they can see that this is
something that needs to be tackled and
we will
we will tackle it by creating many many
hundreds of thousands of high-wage
high-skilled jobs in green technology
and you're and in the green industrial
revolution plan alone uh there are there
are plans for 440 000 more jobs uh in
all sorts of things from from uh
battery technology to wind farms and
many many other things so uh the economy
is going uh this way i think it's a it's
a good thing and uh we can use we can
use this moment to to trigger a greater
growth and greater prosperity but do it
in a green way i do think people people
get that and as for uh your brilliant
suggestion of a referendum mesa i think
that i think sometimes i think this
country's probably had enough
referendums to be going on with uh for a
while that's my general view on the
matter but um uh
anyway beth
thank you prime minister it's been a
really really intense few days both here
in rome
both in rome and in glasgow
um but just to use your football analogy
you talked about being able to equalize
in extra time but isn't the sad reality
of all of this that if china is not on
the pitch
team world is not going to be able to
equalize that is the elephant in the
room isn't it and on
forests sky news is on the ground in
brazil
where authorities don't seem to care at
all about mass
deforestation do you really believe that
the president of brazil will follow
through on the pledges he made is he
taking it seriously thank you
thank you thank you very much first of
all on uh really good questions first of
all on on on china uh yes it's true that
uh uh president xi isn't isn't here uh
but on the other hand the chinese team
is is very high level you know he he he
didn't want i talked to him uh he didn't
want to come because of the of the
pandemic and and you've got to respect
that the same was the case for for
vladimir putin um but that doesn't mean
the chinese are not engaging uh they've
made the commitment on uh on net zero by
the middle of the century by by 2060 or
earlier and the key thing that china is
is saying is that uh they they want to
uh
get to
uh they want to to to get to
a peak in their carbon emissions by 2030
or before
and
when you listen to to what uh
xi jinping says
the question is how much before
because and that's
the issue and that's what we're
discussing
with china because there is still you
know there's a world difference between
peaking in 2030 in your emissions for
from china and peaking in 2025 and so
that's where the conversation is that's
where we're uh we're keeping uh the the
pressure up and on on your point about
forests
um
and and you know we're continuing to
engage with uh with china and and you
know we're seeing some
signs of of progress but do we want more
then that's absolutely true yes we do
but we want more from everybody and just
just on just you want to come to forest
or do you want to do a follow-up on
china
i i think that uh
we need china to to make
commitments uh china is has already made
a substantial commitment in the sense
they've moved to uh to net zero by the
middle of the
of the century uh 2060 or or before as
xi jinping says let's see where we get
to with uh with china and and peaking by
pre-2030 let's see what that adds up to
but you know china has fantastic uh
power to uh make change in its in the
way it runs its economy they've
committed to no new financing of
overseas coal that's a big change or in
you you're starting to see the impact of
that chinese decision to stop financing
coal overseas uh in the whole
asia-pacific region already that you can
see people moving away from fire just at
this cop just in the last couple of days
you'll have seen the pledges that really
follow from that chinese action so i'm
grateful for that do we need more
progress you bet we need more more
progress from from china um and from and
from everybody here at this at this
gathering
on
deforestation
and your point about you know your
reporter in in brazil not finding any
evidence that uh on the ground that
there's any willingness to stop cutting
down trees
it's it's not just uh world leaders who
are who are saying this
what we're doing
is saying that
companies that invest in
commodities or buy commodities
that result from deforestation
whatever whatever they may be uh will
not be
invested in and
you you and there's been an agreement by
companies around the world that they
will no longer support or uh
invest in commodities with palm oil or
whatever uh that a result from
deforestation you've heard you've heard
what the big uh commodity producers
cargill and others have had to say
that's a massive step forward that's a
big change
and secondly
the financial the world's financial
institutions have stepped up and said
that well they won't finance uh
companies that get involved in
deforestation so so financial
institutions worth trillions and
trillions of pounds will not be
supporting deforestation and the the
pressure
comes from consumers around the world
who will say to those banks whether it's
aviva or barclays or whoever else if
they
if they blame if they break that pledge
there will be a a democratic a consumer
price to pay and the same goes for the
the companies that that break that
pledge so there's been a there's been a
big shift in the balance of power i
think over forests towards consumers
towards people who care about it and who
want to stop the forests being chopped
down eve you know whatever governments
even if governments do break the pledges
that they're making do you see what i'm
saying i think and so i think that's
that's been the important thing let's go
to liz piper of reuters
hi prime minister um the developed world
promised in 2020 to deliver the hundred
billion they still haven't done that do
you think there's any what's the
likelihood of it actually coming next
year and surely the price tag should be
a little bit higher also what was your
reaction to india's net zero target
being at 20 70.
uh liz i i thought i think that the 100
billion is still something that we're
pushing for
earlier we're going to get it by 2023 uh
but we need to see we need to see more i
thought that what japan had to say was
great but you know this ain't over we
need we need to we need further action
from
uh from countries around the world and
uh we're going to keep the we're
certainly going to going to keep the
pressure up and
uh sorry liz my move what was your
second question
hey india yeah look uh just just just on
india i think um
the
the most important thing that they've
said
is that they want to decarbonize their
their so much of their their their power
system by 2030 that's a massive
commitment uh
moving up from 175 to 450 gigawatts of
of clean energy uh that's a that's a
huge commitment and if they put that in
their ndc uh even even more powerful
uh harry cole of the sun
thank you very much prime minister you
say the score is now five three but um
who's called
five two i mean you know
i said
it could be even five three who scored
the goals though was it the queen was it
biden was it greta was it you um who's
had the biggest impact on this summit uh
and if i may it seems that president
macron is already back in paris tonight
having seemingly left early was that a
snub after your fallout and could you
possibly clear up whether you did offer
him more generous terms for french
fishing boats
in order to keep talks alive
uh thanks look i i think that it does
it's a it's a it's a team game this
thing
harry
um
i think he is and i i i think
everybody's working very hard together
to to keep 1.5 alive and i think a 1.5
degrees alive and i think a lot of a lot
of pro i would i would pay tribute to
all the uh individuals that um
that you've mentioned or the possible
exception myself but i certainly paid
tribute to everybody for a big big
effort and uh that effort will will
continue uh we will keep going uh right
right to the wire and on our relations
with france i really renew what i've
said before
we are working
very very closely with our french
friends and partners on the things that
matter most to the people of the world
and that is tackling climate change
reducing co2 and uh
by comparison uh with that hugely
important issue the
the ones you mentioned are really
vanishingly unimportant but since you
ask
about whether uh the the uk has uh has
changed its position let me put it that
way change its position on uh on the
fishing issue the answer is no
but i hope that will do folks uh then
thank you all for your your kind
attention thank you thank you
i really yeah it